let's say you're doing an interview for
a job you've thought about why you want
the role and why you want to join the
company but then you get into the
interview room and the interviewer says
Alexis why should we hire you over
everyone else we're considering that's a
pretty open-ended question and it's
pretty tough to answer in the moment or
let's say you're working at an
internship over the summer and you're
meeting with your team to discuss either
an investment opportunity that you have
or some other decision that your team
needs to make and you walk into this
meeting thinking that you're going to
discuss the pros and the cons of the
decision that you're going to make but
instead your manager turns to you and
says Brian should we make this
investment opportunity do you think it's
a good idea or let's say that you're you
know the summer you're going to an
engagement party and your friends who
are getting married ask you to say a few
words a little unexpectedly and you
weren't expecting that so what would you
do in that case if you're starting to
feel a little bit stressed out that's
because you should these questions are
hard especially if you haven't had a
chance to prepare what you're going to
say because speaking on impromptu is
hard and while they represent a wide
range of scenarios from interviews to
business meetings to social settings
they have a lot in common
they all involve unexpected questions
they involve high-stakes situations and
they involve an audience whose opinion
matters to you
and as a result you want to sound both
confident and knowledgeable when you're
speaking even if you haven't had a
chance to prepare
and so we've had--we've through this
class and through the coaching by JD
Stephanie and Burt we've all had a
chance to become blossoming presenters
of prepared material but what happens
when you can't prepare we're here
because we want to help you sound
polished even when what you're really
feeling like is this we're going to walk
you through three scenarios or three
scenarios that I just mentioned
interviews business meetings which could
also apply for class participation at
the GSB and social settings and show you
a framework for each of those that will
help you sound polished even if you
haven't had a chance to prepare so
Sydney's going to walk through what you
can do in an interview setting
Aileen is going to walk through what you
can do in a business setting and finally
matt is going to show you how to adapt
those two frameworks to something that's
of a more personal or social nature as
idd mentioned we are first going to talk
about interviews impromptu speaking in
the context of interviews before coming
to the GSB I was at a company where I
did a lot of interviews and by the end
of it I often felt like this the person
I was talking to had been rambling I
couldn't get to the point I couldn't
understand what was it that they had
really added to that situation so I want
to offer a format for you when you're in
an interview that you can use to help
structure your answers and help your
interviewer understand why you are so
awesome and perfect for the job and that
format is star which stands for
situation task action and result
so I'll give you a little demonstration
starting with situation and the key with
the situation is that you don't want to
give too much detail the tendency is for
people to get into a lot of detail and
the interviewer kind of gets lost in the
situation itself you want to just offer
enough information so that they
understand the context and the stakes so
if I were given the question tell me
about a time when you were up against a
really tight deadline I might say okay I
had six weeks to get our company
compliant with various consumer
protections regulations to meet an
investor requirement and what was at
stake was tens of millions of dollars
very brief and to the point
next the task the task can also be brief
my task was to make sure that we met
that deadline that had been set by
investors so we got the money that we
needed
end of story and then action this is
where you want to spend most of your
time you really want to help the
interviewer understand what is your
thought process what did you do and why
did you do it so in this case I started
with a project plan and I talked to
various people across the company to try
to understand how were they going to be
impacted by these regulations and what
did we need to change I came up with the
project plan and after getting buy-in I
followed up really frequently to make
sure we were actually on track because
we are up against such a tight deadline
and finally the results again the result
can be very short and sweet the result
of this situation was that we met the
deadline because of my work you want to
make sure that you again give the
interviewer a reason to believe that you
were the one that made this all happen
and we got the money that we need it so
hopefully that is a helpful example of
how you can master interviewer
interviews and help your interviewer see
why you are so
right for the job another professional
setting where you might be asked to
speak impromptu is in meetings in
meetings servoz might approach you and
say Anna our socialist quarter has
decreased by 10 percent
what do you think we could do or David
do you think we should invest in this
new investment opportunity and both of
the scenarios a good structure that
could help you out of anxiety is cry
perhaps stands for point reason example
and point you could start your speech
with a really strong point of argument
and then support it with a specific
reason you can then move on to a
concrete example showing why your point
is if you want to follow and agree on
and to make sure that your audience
didn't forget what your point is after
so much content even in between you can
close your speech again stating the
point you might want to ask why is prep
a specific good structure to follow the
major reason is that it can draw in
audiences of a bit of different
backgrounds research has shown that
recent appeals to our logical left head
while examples and stories of kills to
our emotional right head so say if you
are in a high stick meeting or cross
functional meeting where you have people
who both tend to think what were you
both have people tends to think more
logically two people for the technology
side at the same time you also have
audience who are easy to resonate
emotionally for example the people from
the sales side prepa such good structure
that could make sure that your speech
stays balanced and you don't
unfortunately lose half of your audience
by either focusing too much on the
logical reasons or purely on examples or
stories now let's look at an example of
how we could use practice equity say you
work in a traditional brick-and-mortar
Taylor and you want to suggest
strengthening your online silver so in
admitting you might want to add you
might want to use prep and start like
this
we should gradually move our offline
sales focus and capital to online sales
the major reason is that during the past
years we've seen offline sales
decreasing while online sales go in all
pills in fact our major competitor of
Best Buy closed over thousands of its
stores earlier this year and turn them
into distribution centers for online
sales which has increased online sales
of 30% for the company therefore I
strongly suggest it shifts from offline
sales to online sales C press is
actually very easy to use and can make
sure that your impromptu speech stays
balanced in structured so the next time
when your boss approaches you're in the
mid and asked you what to do to stop the
soil slot sales lies or whether the
company should invest in a new
investment opportunity don't panic
think of a point reason example talk
about them in a consistent structured
way and end your speech with the point
again in fact if you looked at what we
went through just now you can easily
find that actually use prep to structure
my own speech to introduce prep to you
all we first talked about the point that
prep is a great structure to use in
impromptu speaking and meetings in the
major reason being that it can blind
audiences of different backgrounds we
then move on to exempt you of online
sales offline sales and I close my
speech again by stating the point and
then encourage you to use prep in your
next meetings so if you feel good about
using prep why didn't start using it in
your next GSB meetings with their fouls
next we want to talk to you about
impromptu speaking and social or
personal settings now we all know this
can be particularly intimidating I know
when I was asked to give a toast at my
dad's wedding reception without knowing
I was going to have to do it I was
absolutely terrified but thankfully just
like we saw with the frameworks they
showed for interviews and meetings there
are simple structures you can have in
mind beforehand that'll make the
experience much more comfortable and
easy for you to give an impromptu speech
in a social setting so before I
introduce those structures I want to ask
by show of hands who's been to talk
right now if you've been to talk you
guys probably know that people often
start their talk by telling a story if
you remember back to Sidney's talk she
gave us the story about how she started
playing the bassoon then she went on to
talk about what that Illustrated about
her and her personality and as you might
guess there's a reason that people start
their talk by telling a story for those
same reasons you should use them when
you have to give an impromptu speech in
a social or personal setting first of
all telling a story engages the audience
when you're in a social setting people
can be talking to each other instead of
listening to you and it's a lot more
engaging to listen to a story than it is
to listen to a set of facts or figures
that you're regurgitating and second
it's impromptu and it's a lot easier for
you to try to recount the story that you
know well than it is to try to memorize
things right beforehand and rattle off a
list of facts that you might not have a
good handle on thankfully the second
part of the structure is also pretty
simple just explicitly make the point
that the story Illustrated it might be
as simple as describing what the story
made you think or how it made you feel
if you're giving a wedding toast it
might be describing how the story
Illustrated to you how good of a match
the bride and groom are or if it's a
birthday toast it might be how the story
illustrate just how good of a friend
that person is again the value in this
structure is that it's something that's
familiar and known to you and it'll be
easier for you to recount convincingly
to your audience and lastly just finish
strong and whatever manner is
appropriate for the setting you're in it
might be as simple as raising a glass
and asking everyone to celebrate with
you but don't apologize and don't be
afraid to reiterate your point it'll
just help to drive home your message and
it'll make you enjoy the speech that
much more so we've all learned in this
class to stand and appreciate our
applause if you use this structure
you'll have an easier more enjoyable
time
giving your next personal impromptu
speech and you'll be able to enjoy it
more great so we've just heard three
techniques for how you can be better at
impromptu speaking and sound prepared
even if our sound polished even if you
haven't prepared now we want to invite
you to use this the next time that
you're on one of these nerves all of you
are going to be interviewing for jobs
the summer in the fall or going to be
doing internships and many of us are
going to be attending weddings or other
celebrations over the summer so there's
a lot of opportunities in your immediate
future to take a step back and reach for
one of these three techniques whichever
one speaks the most your personal style
and use them